>> Dana: NOW TO THE CRISIS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
A GROWING NUMBER OF MIGRANTS
INFECTED WITH CORONAVIRUS
TRYING TO ENTER THE U.S. SIMPLY
ADDING TO THE CHAOS.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM SAYS HE HAS HAD ENOUGH
AND PRESSING THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY FOR ANSWERS.
>> WHAT I’M ASKING THE HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY TO DO IS
TELL ME AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OF THE MILLION PEOPLE YOU’VE
APPREHENDED, HOW MANY OF THEM
HAVE BEEN RELEASED INTO THE
UNITED STATES, HOW MANY OF THEM
DO YOU TEST, WHAT’S THE
POSITIVE RATE, WHAT’S THE
SYSTEM IN PLACE TO TEST PEOPLE
BEFORE THEY ARE RELEASED INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Dana: TOM HOMAN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER ACTING
DIRECTOR OF ICE.
OFFICER CUELLAR REPRESENTS THIS
AREA AND IS A DEMOCRAT.
WATCH.
>> IN THE VALLEY THERE WERE 70
AGENTS THAT HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE IN THE LAREDO AREA
ANOTHER 15.
IT IS NOT ONLY THE AGENTS BUT
ALSO THEIR FAMILIES WHEN THEY
GO HOME.
SO WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE OUR
MEN AND WOMEN OF HOMELAND AND
WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE THE
BORDER COMMUNITIES.
>> Dana: LOCAL SERGEANT THERE
SAID THEY DIDN’T KNOW AND
WEREN’T TOLD IT WAS HAPPENING
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES, TOM.
>> WELL, REPRESENTATIVE CUELLAR
IS A PATRIOT.
HE PUT POLITICS ASIDE AND
TELLING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
TRUTH.
HE IS RIGHT.
THANK GOD FOR ASKING THIS
QUESTION.
I APPRECIATE IT.
OVER 20CBA AGENTS HAVE DIED
FROM COVID IN THE LINE THE DUTY
DEATHS.
IT IS NOT JUST COVID.
IT IS TB.
THEY TAKE  CHICKEN POX AND
THEY’RE IN A TOUGH SPOT.
AS FAR AS THE PREVIOUS FROM
SENATOR GRAHAM I CAN ANSWER
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS.
THE DHS GAVE THE NUMBER 55,000
RELEASED, ORDERED TO REPORT TO
ICE.
ACTUALLY 166,000 ALIENS HAVE
BEEN RELEASED IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IT IS ACTUALLY OVER 63,000 THAT
HAVE RELEASED AND SAID WE’LL
LEAVE IT UP TO YOU TO REPORT TO
ICE.
VERY FEW OF THEM ARE REPORTING
TO ICE.
OUT OF THE 102,000 RELEASED
WITH NOTICE TO APPEARS TO GO TO
COURT, VERY FEW OF THEM ARE
SHOWING UP FOR COURT.
THAT’S THE NUMBERS.
THE NUMBERS RIGHT NOW YESTERDAY
1,000 ILLEGAL ALIENS WERE
ARRESTED ON THE BORDER.
RIGHT NOW BORDER PATROL --
1,000 YESTERDAY WERE RELEASED
WITH A NOTICE TO REPORT TO ICE.
1,000 JUST YESTERDAY.
THEY ARRESTED 7,000 ILLEGAL
ALIENS IN ONE DAY YESTERDAY.
800 CHILDREN ARRESTED YESTERDAY.
14,000 IN CUSTODY AT BORDER
PATROL NOW.
THAT’S THE NUMBERS THE DHS IS
TRYING TO HIDE FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Bill: THEY’RE EFFECTIVELY
RELEASING COVID POSITIVE
MIGRANTS INTO THE UNITED STATES
WITHOUT ANY BEARING ON THEM TO
SHOW UP FOR COURT DATE OR A
MEDICAL CHECKUP OR ANYTHING.
HERE IS LA JOYA, TEXAS SERGEANT.
LISTEN TO THIS.
CALL FOR TWO.
IT READS LIKE WE DID NOT KNOW
THIS.
NO ONE TOLD THE CITY OF LA
JOLLA, NO ONE TOLD THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT THESE PEOPLE WERE
HERE AND NO ONE TOLD US THESE
PEOPLE WERE POSSIBLY ILL.
A GROUP OF FAMILIES GATHERED AT
A LOCAL RESTAURANT.
TOM, IF YOU ARE COVID POSITIVE
YOU CAN’T FLY HERE FROM LONDON,
ENGLAND.
IF YOU’RE COVID POSITIVE YOU
CAN WALK INTO THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA ACROSS THE
SOUTHWESTERN BORDER.
>> LOOK, IT’S RIDICULOUS.
THE NORTHERN BORDER IS STILL
CLOSED TO COVID.
THEY ASK AMERICANS TO MASK UP
AGAIN AND GO DOOR-TO-DOOR ON
VACCINATION CHECKS.
SOUTHERN BORDER IS WIDE OPEN.
166,000 THAT HAVE BEEN RELEASED
SO FAR UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN,
HOW MANY OF THEM ARE POSITIVE
COVID?
WE KNOW FOR A FACT DHS HAS
RELEASED HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
WITH COVID CASES.
WE KNOW THAT THE BORDER PATROL
IS NOT TESTING.
95% OF THE BORDER THERE IS NO
TESTING BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO COVID CASES ARE COMING
ACROSS THAT BORDER.
ICE ALONE HAS HAD OVER 7500
POSITIVE COVID CASES RUN
THROUGH THEIR SYSTEM.
TODAY THEY HAVE OVER 1200
POSITIVE CASES IN CUSTODY THAT
CAME ACROSS THAT BORDER.
LET’S REMEMBER ICE GETS A VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS CROSSING THAT BORDER.
95% ARE RELEASED.
IF I TEST 1200 IN CUSTODY HOW
MANY HAVE BEEN RELEASED WITH
POSITIVE CASES.
IT IS INCOMPETENCE AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL.
>> Bill: THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL TELL YOU YOU NEED A
VACCINE OR YOU CAN’T WORK THERE.
WHAT WILL THEY SAY TOMORROW
FROM THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF?
WAITING TO HERE ON THAT.
YOU CAN’T TO GO A CLASSROOM IN
AMERICA IN AUGUST OR SEPTEMBER
UNLESS YOU ARE WEARING A MASK.
ALL THIS STUFF IS WELL UPSIDE